for joining us now baris cumberland who
led the review um that neil just
mentioned there into those other
scandals including the pregnancy drug
primados um baroness thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon i know you
were able to listen to kit malthouse
there and the government's response to
this compensation scheme which to be
frank
seems really messy and it's such an
important issue you wonder how the
government is proceeding with this some
people getting payments they're interim
some people not questions over
eligibility what's your reaction to
what's been announced today
well can i say i am delighted that
people who have suffered so much through
no fault of their own are getting some
redress some compensation
and we are calling the government to
ensure that the people who have suffered
through two medications
and through the insertion of surgical
mesh should also be compensated we're
calling it redress because compensation
needs to be awarded through the courts
and we don't want these sick and
vulnerable people having to go through
the courts so we're asking the
government to give redress
yeah it's today the day to step up the
pressure on the government because your
report concluded back in 2020 one of the
recommendations was compensation victims
of those three scandals that your report
covered you mentioned there still
fighting for compensation kit morehouse
the government minister said you know
that's not for today but i will look
into it what would you like to say to
kit malthouse he's he seems to be
listening today
well we certainly want redress for those
people and their families who have
suffered so much and that was a major
recommendation in our report and we have
been fighting for it but clearly we're
going to have to persuade the government
and we're hoping that whoever is the new
prime minister will put this on the top
of their must-do list because these
people
need
financial support
for all the suffering that they have had
and for their future
yeah
what happened to them not just
life-changing but for so many
life-ending many people affected by
these scandals
will not live to see the redress that
you seek on their behalf your report in
conclusion made nine recommendations
have any of them been implemented
yes over half
and
we are delighted we have a patient
safety commissioner who has been
appointed and this person henrietta
hughes is going to ensure that patients
are always put first and foremost and
their needs are met as far as possible
we've also had an apology from the
secretary of state which we asked for
and we also said that there should be
mesh centers set up for the people who
have so suffered through the insertion
of mesh and those have been set up nine
of them across the country in nine
different regions
so recommendations that you made as you
said over half of them put in place but
it is still the money issue
isn't it in terms of
what that would do for victims of these
scandals explain to us because your
report alone looking into three scandals
your
your um review board spoke to over 700
people affected and of course there were
thousands more talk to me about what
this money would do for them and how it
would help them
well first of all it really is important
that they get some redress and it is
people who are having to look after
disabled children for instance uh
families who are having to look after
their mothers who've had mesh inserted
and so on and so those people do need
some financial redress
and we're saying we're not going for
things that are already provided in the
nhs and social care this is in addition
to that and also we know that there are
people who really need support for
hospital appointments the cost of those
the travel involved and so there are
other issues that really need some
consideration and also some money to
help those people lead better lives
how complicated is the issue of
financial redress in terms of there has
been a mixed response to the
compensation announced by the government
today to those affected by um the
infected blood scandal because
those directly affected and spouses get
compensation but as it stands at the
moment the children of parents who are
affected or the parents of children who
are affected do not receive anything
how big a hurdle is that in terms of so
many people have been affected not just
directly there is a ripple effect when
scandals like this happen is that what
is slowing the process down do you think
yes of course you're quite right it does
need working through but we've looked at
the numbers and we believe that the
amount of money that um is required is
not huge it's not eye-watering and the
treasury should
really look at that and understand the
value that it would give to people's
lives if they got some help some address
some financial reward and so we're
saying we have got the numbers we need
that it's
42 or so million that we need for
our people who suffered mesh 20 million
for those for sodium vaporate and much
less for those from primidos the other
um uh
pharmaceutical um
uh
apart
that was put the people have suffered
and that's about a million so it's not
eye-watering it's rarely achievable and
it would just make such a difference
yeah they sound like big figures when
you break it down to the thousands
affected it's not at all and as you said
it's for them to
be able to receive medical treatments to
live a comfortable life um
i was just wondering if you could talk
to us about the human side of this story
because today we are talking about
numbers we're talking about financial
compensation but you have spoken to so
many people affected by these um medical
scandals
can you give us the human side to it
what have people said to you what is it
they want we talk about redress but it's
peace of mind it's an apology it's a
chance to to move on
well certainly we spent two and a half
years just listening to patients
listening to their families
listening to
uh the tremendous traumas that they'd
been through and it was
really tragic that women who had had
mesh
lost their jobs because they were too
ill to work because they lost their job
they then couldn't pay the mortgage
because they couldn't pay the mortgage
they then were homeless because they
they were homeless there was a real risk
that their children would be taken into
care
so it was
downward spiral and the suffering that
we witnessed i will take to my grave it
was simply appalling the huge effects
that it had and of course some of the
people had actually died well veronica
campbell as you continue to fight on
their behalf and thank you for speaking
up for those victims today
we appreciate your time here on sky news
thank you very much